what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
looking at the latest developments in
the demon Slayers story and we finally
got to see the return of some of my
favorite characters so stay tuned for
that if you enjoy these Demon Slayer
videos and want to keep them coming make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or else you
will miss new Demon Slayer videos when
they come out before I release them on
YouTube I upload these chapter reviews
on Spotify and Apple podcasts so to get
sneak previews on the top two reviews
make sure you are following anime up or
audio wherever you listen to podcast you
can find the links in the description
obviously there will be manga spoilers
in this video we are talking about the
latest chapter chapter 190 after all now
without further ado let's jump into it
we start this chapter with iguras still
gripping his now red blade if you'll
remember ego had just turned his blade
red your each sheet the strongest team
is here in history and the only man that
ever beat Mouzon had a red blade red
blaze represented the power of the Sun
the natural weakness of the demons as a
result when demons are cut with red
blades it reduces their ability to
regenerate quickly Iguodala with his new
blade looked like he was going to
completely kick butt at the end of last
chapter but that would have been too
easy at the beginning of this chapter it
is revealed that when eager to first saw
his red and blade he thought he made a
mistake because everything in his sight
went white just making the blade turn
red used too much energy so he couldn't
land an effective attack on a demon King
of Pop it's funny moves on this whole
time has pretty much been standing in
place and waving around his demon
tentacles I'm actually surprised by how
ineffective his attacks have been for
the most part I said in the last chapter
review that things look bad for Mouzon
because he hasn't been able to kill four
pillars without red weapons and
eventually is going to have to fight
even more people and they may all have
red weapons by that point so yeah even
though he's the big bad boss villain of
the series he's gonna need some kind of
upgrade if he really hopes to stand a
chance of winning this now let's jump
back to a guru who's sweating and seeing
white he puts so much strength into his
grip in the middle of battle
he almost passed out from lack of oxygen
this brief moment of almost passing out
throws him off to the point where he
almost gets hit by Mullins demon
tentacle son Amy screams out his name
because he's worried about him maybe
it's just me but it's nice seeing son of
me the big jerk of the series clearly
caring about eager oh it warms my heart
it really does eager for his part is
worried he knows that if he falls out
every other pillars burden will be
increased
he knows this but at the same time he's
not in a position to block or dodge
Amazon's attack he says that he's
fighting for me to reshare which is
admirable of him he wants to step up so
that meets early the sexy woman he loves
doesn't have to endanger her own life
anymore
still though despite his best intentions
ego can't feel anything but his hands
and it seems like he's about to get hit
Hugh tries to return the favor and save
a girl like eager to save him a little
bit ago but he's too late yet magically
eager Oh appears in the air completely
fine moves on is shocked he goes in to
try to hit him but his demons had to
close get cut Mouzon realizes that
something's off the cut is not like
Gomez or economies Angie went to save
agura
so he was nowhere near him eager oh it's
too far to reach moves on to then moves
on notices that the blade doesn't cut
cleanly it's a jagged blade and by now
us hardcore fans should know that this
has to be in Oscars place this appears
to be the work of useless technique
blindfold which lets him mask some
things or somebody's presence using
paper talisman on the cover page of this
chapter three hands were seen holding
these paper talismans so it would make
sense that he knows Ches and Sue Ann
Connell ran into you shadow and used his
powers to make themselves invisible they
have finally arrived and are now
fighting moves on the pillars have
reinforcements and ushiro again got to
help in the fight against Mouzon he
might really end up being the MVP of
this fight when all is said and done
after all they wouldn't even be fighting
outside if it wasn't for you shootas
genjutsu on document soon enough moves
on notices that there are three people
and he destroys all the paper towels
means next thing you know we see Khan
out in those scans any - dear God it is
nice to see them back in the story it's
been way too long let me - in particular
showed huge progress in his last fight
so that I
been dying to see him fight again his
lightning dragon move that he used
against the new upper moon 6ky gaku was
beyond epic and I can't wait to see him
step it up even further in this fight of
course the first things I need to does
is act as comedic relief after he's hit
with an exaggerated expression he cries
out how dare you to move out as if moves
on it's supposed to be nice to him in
this fight to the death
canal is just surprised that moves on
could figure out what was going on so
quickly any no escape the manly man a
demon slayer calls moves on a filthy
maggot Yomi is surprised they're alive
and in one translation he knows he calls
the strongest pillar an idiot and asks
him if he saw him die clearly he knows
he is willing to insult anyone no matter
if they're his senior or if they're way
stronger than him or if they're the
demon king of Pop himself and you can't
help but respect him for that he also
reveals that he's carrying a bunch of
paper talisman so everyone could
potentially become invisible
enos k invites moves on to cut as many
of the papers as he can since he's got a
bunch and even goes on to call moose ons
attacks pitiful before he lets out a
scream while dodging an especially close
attack he no skis as insulting as ever
and I love it I'm always entertaining no
skis on screen or I guess on panel in
this case he's even getting two moves on
who tells him to cut the unnecessary
chatter we then jump to my boy Iguodala
catches moves on off guard with an
awesome snake slash he takes some
tentacles off but these don't grow back
immediately it's not quite like when
moves on thought you're Ichi back Benny
was almost like his regeneration
straight up stop for a while here Muslim
is still regenerating but as Sonny
points out he's regenerating slower
because of the red blade Cano ends any
to keep using the papers for
invisibility kind of looks serious and
zani too in his usual hilarious fashion
looks like the biggest crybaby since osa
still though he's fighting and we know
we can count on him when the chips are
down decided so in camo attack moves on
who's upset he says they are pesky flies
and that they have nothing but pitiful
tricks but still he's extremely upset
suggesting that they are getting to him
clearly moves on is not as in control of
this situation as he'd like to be he
probably expected to have one already
and here he is fighting
creasing number of opponents and he
can't even finish one off my boy Egor
makes another move I knew we'd see some
awesome things from him since he got his
power upgrade at the end of the last
chapter and he's delivered he slashes
moves on from a bunch of angles again
and gets away without Moe's on landing a
hit on him we jump to Gil Mei who points
out the improved situation iguras blade
is now red and their numbers have
increased with the addition of zani to
canal and eNOS K hopefully those three
will be awakening their Demon Slayer
marks soon I still want to see my boys
and itsu rec moves on with some upgraded
lightning dragon rules but for now while
we wait for that we got Gil me realizing
that all of these favorable
circumstances have opened up some space
for him to do something the gentle giant
of demon slayers hits the two ends of
his weapon together and it turns red
like last time when he fought kakushi bo
Yomi notices a burning smell and heat so
the red color is accompanied by intense
heat and burning just like the Sun no
wonder these weapons are so effective
against moves on and other demons Gil
may suggest that the red weapon may not
last long but he's glad that it
increases his offense even temporarily
he gets what must be the most
significant hit on moves on during this
fight he takes out the left side of
muslins chest and the left arm with it
Muslim is not happy I said things look
bad for moves on before and now they
look absolutely horrible sudden he hits
his blade against goos turning both
weapons red GU has finally joined the
red blade Club acro says there is one
hour and three minutes left until dawn
the last panel of the chapter shows
sunny and you looking cool and confident
so enemy says that there's no problem
and that they'll chop moves on into
little pieces and that's what happened
in this chapter moves on as predicted is
doing poorly he didn't have the skill to
finish off four pillars when they were
heavily poisoned and now they're better
thinks that our medicine from Tommy owes
Kat their demon slayers marks have
manifested their blades have turned red
and Zenit Wieniawski and cano have shown
up and the three are even sometimes
invisible yo Mei got a significant hit
taking off almost a quarter of mulan's
body moves on cannot keep up like this
and the story would be kind of boring if
the demon slayers kept crushing him in a
one-sided way that is why I think that
moves on is going to get some kind of
power
upgrade soon keep in mind Tonto and Nez
Zuko haven't even shown up and moles on
the strongest demon is clearly not doing
well sunny is confident that they can
take him and even give who's looked
worried for a large portion of this
fight looks like he's calm and ready to
kick but in the last panel let me know
what do you think is going to happen
what kind of upgrade or transformation
can we expect from moves on does he have
some other trick up his sleeve this is a
common formula and demon slayer working
together the weaker demon Slayers are
able to overcome the stronger demon
opponent the demon Slayers have been
helping each other and making up for
each other's weaknesses it shows how by
working together people with like-minded
goals can make each other stronger and
can accomplish things that none of them
could accomplish alone everyone is
playing their part including ushiro who
keeps being an extremely annoying thorn
and moves on side however there is no
way Muslims gonna be defeated before
nezu ko
and especially tons you to show up to
play their parts in his defeat muslin is
gonna have no choice but to step it up
next chapter then he might turn the
tides for a bit before tangerine Etsuko
come to the rescue
we can still expect any tucano and eNOS
Kay to get demon Ser marks and red blade
upgrades still though this chapter was
too one-sided and I'm expecting that
moves on will turn the tables as early
as the next one with some kind of new
form or secret power we shall see but
this chapter was definitely an eventful
one and I cannot overemphasize how
excited I am that the lightning dragon
manly beast and flower eye trio has
finally returned to the story we got to
see condos vermilion eye and Zen in to
his original lightning dragon move in
their last battles but he knows Kay is
overdue for a power upgrade or new move
I look forward to seeing him shine in
the upcoming chapters let me know what
you're most excited to see at this point
and that is it for today's video thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this chapter review make sure to smash
that like button to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future and even say your chapter
reviews you can find more Demon Slayer
content and important updates on the new
movie and seasons on our twitter and
instagram at anime out drawer and
remember before i release them on
youtube i upload these chapter reviews
on Spotify and Apple pod
castes so to get early access of the
chapter reviews make sure you are
following anime upper audio wherever you
listen to podcasts you can find the
links in the description a special thank
you goes out to our patrons over on
patreon who help us survive YouTube
issues and who helped make videos like
this one possible I especially want to
thank our pro heroes to your patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson kings I'll just $30.00 beat
Anatole Cassatt Sookie
alpha do angel Cruz theme Sparky 65
cricket XP Rohan Kapoor Jessica Maloney
and and / otaku and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stay atop all clans
Steven and Radha a little about them
makoto-kun the world Steelers the school
bus enticing Kirino thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support more by going over to
patreon.com slash anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get named feature
in future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to a private patron a discourse
where we talked about anime life and of
course dank memes so check out patreon
calm animals or link in the description
if you're interested you can also now
join the YouTube channel and support
more content that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see you
space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]